good morning Ben oh
sorry sorry did I scare you no I just
wanted to remind you of the art show
that's happening tonight at the
community center great well that sounds
cool that sounds like uh something that
will be a big success you know
I mean like everything that you uh that
you put your your your paws on your
fingers you guys you guys be cool what's
going on I kind of convinced Ben to
prank you guys and it got a little out
of hand I probably should have said no
to some of his ideas but he's on his way
here right now here he is just be cool
hey guys what's up
um oh I just remembered can I show you
something out to the front area and
leave your cell phones uh because of no
reason just leave anything that can't
get wet actually like you would normally
okay here we go to the parking lot now
wow this is really sad
follow to me guys just go into the
parking lot for normal government
reasons
sorry I can't go through with this I was
gonna pull a prank no yeah I've hired
these guys in ski masks to kidnap us and
I was gonna pretend to be a hero they
were going to shoot me and drive the van
into the river and that's when the
divers would go in pull you guys out of
the water and I would be standing on the
shore like hey get pranked much what the
I haven't got these squibs from a
special effects guy and I was gonna say
this code word and that's when I would
push this button no
[Music]
orange behind me isn't it yeah yeah okay
okay so just keep your eyes open okay
don't panic because you can smell fear
are you talking about hi Hi how are you
good how are you how's it going run
let's have fun it's Halloween you love
Halloween
hey I know it would cheer you up let's
go wait outside the bathroom for Tom and
scare him that would cheer me up
Jerry God gross
oh Jerry guys
oh god oh I think he might be having a
heart attack what
what are you serious oh
[Music]
so much stuff game over Tammy
you I'm going in
oh my God I am so turned on right now
what is what is with you oh yeah tell me
you're not feeling this you are so crazy
[Music]
you're too late
[Music]
I'd do anything for Ron even spend a
whole night fighting his crazy ex-wife
I think I'm safe
just gotta be tired right now
okay deep breath
hey Jerry you put propane in the Eternal
Flame right no they were out and so I
just got a big thing of lighter fluid
it's kind of the same thing oh
I am very sorry I I guess I put too much
fuel in the torch oh I don't know Jerry
I think you're being hard on yourself
yes
I stole nothing
it's okay everything's fine just wheel
out the backup cake there's no backup
cake who doesn't cupcake okay well that
seals it even Leslie is crazier than we
are
they're still going to serve that cake
right
oh sorry what's happening I can't hear
and I'm dying maybe relax I just wanted
to surprise you open the bottom drawer
and read the cake
will you go to prom with me well this
just keeps getting weirder who the hell
is pregnant what I found a pregnancy
test at your cabin and I checked with
all the girls over there it wasn't any
of them
Hello darling what a surprise hey
we talk maybe in private
[Music]
I mean I would be insane not to take the
job but I'm just having some trouble
thinking about leaving Pony hey here's
someone who may be able to convince you
hello Mrs Obama
Grant how you doing
I'm good this is Leslie Knope she's
considering a job with us running the
new Midwest Bureau in Chicago well you
know how I feel about Chicago you are
from Chicago so you like it a few years
ago Eagleton put up this wall along the
border now in it is time to tear down
this wall
[Applause]
former eagletonians the first strike
take it guys
it's such a great day for me
there may be a method to their Madness
there's more than one way to skin a cat
four there's four ways to skin a cat
coyote trap dude
this hurts yeah we got like a huge
Vermin problem I mean it wouldn't be
meaning to call somebody about it but
you know nobody get on the phone you're
the people you would be calling that is
so trippy ow you're fired you're fired
the whole department is fired oh this
hurts this was one of my running feet
it's so nice to see you so happy about a
guy thanks I don't know when I look at
my life right now it feels almost
perfect I mean we have to sneak around
but weirdly it's kind of fun that nobody
knows
hello Leslie how long have you been
sleeping with Ben
look at me
okay here's what's happened let's see
what's going down in babytown
there's your healthy baby oh wow
oh and there's another one the baby has
two bodies twins
Ben we're having twins
no you're not because look who's hiding
over here
triplets
here's a fourth I'm so sorry no it's a
little Fleck of cream cheese on the
screen
just triplets let's talk plans for
Diane's baby shower dear God woman three
main activities baby bingo baby food
tasting and my personal favorite baby
onesie decorating station I'm gonna make
mine look like an astronaut what are you
doing up there in space baby oh so cute
okay I have some gift ideas I was
looking at a very adorable stroller we
already have a stroller I oh shoot
really I have to think of something else
that would be mine guys get in
here we're on cool maybe thank you
Andrew everyone I'd like to introduce
you to my son John middle name redacted
Swanson John was born some time ago
weighing multiple pounds and several
ounces much like his father he is a fan
of silence please keep your voices down
how am I supposed to keep my voice down
when you had your baby
why would you need to know something
like that oh my God
I had not even said Diana gift she's
just walking around wondering why I
haven't sent her a gift yet should we do
something just let her Tire herself out
if you need anything from us trying to
please just let us know actually there
is something could one of you please
stop by the pet store and pick up some
fish food for me